tonight on the show we've got one of the
stars of Game of Thrones will I find out
if Daenerys Targaryen marches with the
unsullied on King's Landing will star a
barbarian fine Lord Baelish at
Winterfell is this the one with Gollum
in it I don't know I just I gave the
Thrones for some people it's an epic
fantasy TV series for other people
Game of Thrones simply musical chairs
Game of Thrones is so huge now artery it
now is the most successful TV show in
the world it's it's the most illegally
downloaded show the highest viewing
figures ever for HBO show is it 14 Emmys
so rebel are you a big fan of Game of
Thrones I have to admit I'd never seen
game of Sir
when you need to be roughly other
services have a TV
congratulations on the finale which
rocked the world
it drove people crazy yes and you must
have read that script with some
trepidation I did yeah a different page
yeah and they're gone yeah Rock gift
wrap gift but also your old mother
doesn't watch Game of Thrones does she
no she stopped after season 1 episode I
don't know what it was it was when some
guys arm got ripped off his body good
noise over there
oh she rang me and she said no it's too
much I'm not doing any more no and like
she decided to pick it up again later on
yeah but chose just the wrong episode
scissor poses which is when I was having
my love scene in a cave so got a second
call going no darling
that's a very good noise love scene in a
cave
oh very good
we don't know who it's going to next oh
yeah
take that card enemy
it is it because it's the hobbit there's
Lord of the Rings you it's a lot of me
refuses it is getting very confusing
yeah I got involved in sewing on that I
was in a I was in a bar this is entirely
embarrassing I walked up to these these
girls who were with my friend and he
introduced them I think he's kind of you
know this is my famous actor friend sort
of I thought this is great you know and
and as I was walking where I was can I
get your drink as a walking right it was
done things have never seen Lord of the
Rings obviously just still look like a
hobbit no you do not know what I do what
I took away from that story ladies
gentleman was that kid Harrington buys
people's drinks all right now one of the
people who sadly didn't make it was of
course relate husband
khal drogo yeah yes ooh there's a whiff
of Conan about there we go well yes
there is
yes yes and all the stuff with him see
my dog butl yes but but Bernie the walls
some levity involved he wasn't that was
he's a he's a funny man and just look
man he doesn't know me but he can be
very funny a little bit of whiskey and
he's very funny oh really but it's
bringing in the darkest seeds in the
darkest scenes yeah so there was there
was there was the beloved the lovely and
rape scene where I read what happened
kind of early on in season 1 and he
tried to colleges yeah that's nervous
laughter
so yeah obviously there's nudity and you
kind of to try and like lighten the mood
not only was it a sex scene but it was a
kind of violent sex scene so he decided
to for one of the scenes which was on
his back and my face he decided to not
use a modesty sock but use a beautiful
pink fluffy sock so getting that
close-up from me looking petrified and
just like did I didn't want it to happen
with just lots of laughter
yeah
he came to the set off Game of Thrones
the Queen yes in your face yeah but a
picture over there she is
she looks so unimpressed they asked they
kept trying to push her to sit down on
the throne and we kept getting told the
same thing which is she's not allowed to
sit on other Thrones fictional or
otherwise there's a thing for that
happen I'm afraid did you talk to her I
did yes
yeah and she was delightful but what he
talked about what not much she asked me
a question I said yes ma'am and then she
moved on now we have to know what did
she ask you it could mean anything
and what do you do on this production
you said yes I said yes maximise she
said oh wonderful have moved on and then
they also under certain Thrones she said
looks very uncomfortable we've done this
character is the closest to yourself
you've ever played yeah in in that I'm
not really like Khaleesi mother of
dragons yeah
yes that's what I'm much closer to leave
definitely cuz immediately in Game of
Thrones which is everywhere it's like a
top tier it's in every country but
boyfriends or friends of you but I
believe your parents Amelia we're bit
worried because you didn't have that
much to do in the first few episodes no
no yes yes so there's this some episodes
that maybe they're like no it was great
but you're sort of not really on very
much are you but but then I did
encourage them to watch the last not
this last episode with the episode
before which in hindsight might have
been not the episode to choose there's a
lot of you in that it was a little bit
yes there was yes that might be the
episode to dip into me and I can really
see how you're doing okay we've just got
a far away shot but the camera did go
right in there and did you or did you
watch it with your parents get between
no right no no I mean did you watch it
with your parents yes cuz that is quite
eggy yeah did you have to leave the room
or did you all just sit there just gotta
go
okay we're watching this yeah no
probably started talking about something
really important like Top Gear how hard
was it doing your dad your Sean Bean
with your dad yes but did you know
you're gonna be your dad
in moonbeam was your dad
it's got many lighter moments than you'd
imagine it's great let me talk about
your cameos so but you didn't know Sean
Bean was gonna be your dad but then you
have to do his accent well they we they
asked him I did my own RP accent when I
auditioned for the role but they asked
Sean whether he could do an RP anyone
know so then they turn to us and went
well you're all doing northern they to
watch so many o2 adverts back to back
things that you make him say no to
adverse event astok everyone twelve
Monkeys get your free dog and bone and
nonsense I do have one slight request
from you though and so would you would
you be able to ask me how I'm doing
Oh
you can say no ever don't hate you but
you can say no no yes well since I know
I've been up to speed on the show yes
thank you
how you doing yeah that's what was
really embarrassing is wouldn't Matt
walked out I went oh you do and then I
was shut up as the ladies go boys
so you but on the show David Beckham
you've got met your match
Oh